today on the matt wall show as we learn
more about the sexuality camps for
children that have proliferated across
the country apparently footage services
of pete budage's husband at a gay camp
recently uh leading kids in a pledge of
allegiance to the pride flags we'll
discuss that plus the house passes a
massive spending bill with all kinds of
goodies for left-wing causes and also
for ukraine while americans get the uh
short shrift once again and the head of
cpac admits that he personally cut the
pro-life panel from the conservative
conference this year we'll listen to his
reasoning and see if we find it
convincing and a black man punches and
kills a white man for saying the n-word
and he was sentenced to house arrest for
it finally in our daily cancellation
we'll assess the claims made by a
married couple who claim that they have
never argued one time in 30 years of
marriage where's the fun in that i ask
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you know the pro-life movement has
to maintain its momentum now more than
ever and what better way to help than by
supporting the charities and causes that
you care about even if the supreme court
were to strike down roe v wade abortion
will still exist in america and many
states across the country that's why we
still have to stay focused on this issue
always charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life
pro-family charity of your choice with
five percent of your monthly plan price
and they have sent millions of dollars
to charities so far
um there are a lot of perks that come
with this as well new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
when you mention offer code walsh
charity mobile makes it easy to switch
you can keep your existing phone number
and you might be able to keep your
existing phone as well if you want a new
phone though no problem charity mobile
has a variety of options from the latest
5g phones to low-cost smartphones and
basic flip phones as well they even have
a phone with parental controls that
allows you to disable and password
protect wi-fi and cellular data usage
and if you are going to get a phone for
your kids
i could not recommend going this route
enough and of course you know charity
mobile is going to provide options like
that because this is a family-friendly
company there are no contracts no
termination fees and no risk with a
30-day guarantee so switch to charity
mobile and support the causes you care
about call them at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh
so there's a famous story about hernan
cortez that i think i've told before
where the spanish conquistador landed in
mexico in the early 1500s and proceeded
to um you know topple the mighty aztec
empire with only his small gang of
soldiers and the indian allies that he
made along the way now as the story goes
early upon their arrival
some of cortez's men were restless and
antsy and afraid as you might expect
and not fully committed to the tasks so
so cortez wanting to take away any
temptation
or the ability to flee he made the
decision to scuttle his own ships
um he intentionally sank the boats that
he came in effectively stranding himself
and his men in this unknown land because
the message was clear there's no going
back there's nowhere to run this is
where we are we're out here in this
hostile wilderness so you might as well
prepare to fight
it's the only choice you have so you got
to just commit to it cortez was totally
outnumbered he was in a place he didn't
know controlled by a violent enemy an
enemy which preferred to capture you
alive
and and rather than kill you in battle
so that they could take you up to up
their temple and cut out your heart and
sacrifice you to their war gods
cortez had put himself in a position
where now he would either have victory
or he would have his heart cut out there
was no third option so full commitment
was the only way forward i think about
the story a lot because i find striking
parallels between cortez's situation
and our own in our culture today now we
as conservatives obviously we're not
we're not facing the prospect of having
our hearts cut out of our chests not yet
anyway but we do confront an enemy who
engages in its own form of human
sacrifice and is much more efficient and
prolific in that regard than the aztecs
ever were
but mainly though it's that if you're
not an adherent to the leftist religion
no matter how else you identify yourself
you know no matter what political label
you claim for yourself if you're not an
adherent to the leftist religion
then you are living in a totally hostile
environment you are living in an empire
ruled by forces that hate you
you have no institutional power
you also have no way out there's nowhere
else to go so you might as well commit
fully to the fight
i think the situation was made even
clearer over the past few weeks as we've
watched what's happened in response to
the florida anti-groomer bill which
we've discussed extensively on this show
because by the way it's one of the most
important things happening
for americans right now i know
everyone's focused on ukraine but this
is an important thing happening for
americans in america if you care about
your own country
the bill would merely prevent the sexual
indoctrination of children aged in
grades 3 and younger
it would as you know prohibit teachers
from teaching six-year-olds about sexual
orientation and transgenderism and so on
things that no decent person wants
teachers to talk to little kids about
anyway
but as we've covered the left controls
the flow of information in this country
so much that they've been able to
rebrand this bill with absurd falsehoods
and fabrications pretending that it
outlaws the word gay from schools and
even from the entire state
yesterday jen pasaki was asked to weigh
in or rather you know she was asked to
speak for the white house as she does
um what does the white house think of
all of this and of course she echoed the
familiar narrative let's listen
i think that you have seen the president
speak passionately about his view
that a bill like this
a bill that would
discriminate against families against
kids
put these kids in a position of not
getting the support they need
at a time where that's exactly what they
need is discriminatory it's a form of
bullying
it is horrific i mean the president has
spoken to that in terms of his views and
comments from 25 years ago i think the
most important question now is why are
florida leaders deciding they need to
discriminate against kids who are
members of the lgbtqi community what
prompts them to do that is it meanness
is it wanting to make kids have more
difficult times in school in their
communities i would pose that question
to them and we can talk about it more
tomorrow if you get an answer so kids
are bullied uh she says by not being
sexualized and groomed
it is horrific she says to not talk to
little boys and girls about their sexual
orientation that that horrifies her the
idea of not talking to six-year-olds
about uh their sexuality is horrifying
it is discriminatory to refrain from
having sexually inappropriate
conversations with small children that's
the position the white house has taken
but there are institutions far more
powerful in our culture
today than the white house institutions
like disney for example which is why the
saga surrounding disney as it pertains
to this bill has been so revealing now
as we know disney at first took no
position on the anti-groomer bill they
didn't talk about it at all they didn't
say anything but then after a few days
of pressure from the left the ceo sent
out a memo to his staff which we read on
this show a couple days ago reaffirming
his commitment to and deep admiration of
the lgbt community but that wasn't good
enough either so then in the latest
development after another 24 hours of
outrage directed his way finally disney
ceo bob chapic
caved all the way and as cnn reports
disney ceo was criticized money for
speaking out um about but not directly
condemning florida's controversial don't
say gay bill which some with some
feeling that disney's statement fell
short on wednesday chapic agreed with
the criticism quote i understand our
original approach no matter how well
intended didn't quite get the job done
he said during the company's annual
shareholders meeting chapic told a
strong took a stronger stance against
the bill wednesday telling shareholders
that he called florida governor ron
desantis wednesday morning to convey the
company's disappointment and concern
jpeg said that if the legislation
becomes law it quote could be used to
unfairly target gay lesbian non-binary
and transgender kids and families
the well it's you can't really target
non-binary and transgender kids because
um
that they that doesn't exist in reality
the governor heard our concerns and
agreed to meet with me and lgbtq plus
members of our senior team in florida to
discuss ways to address them
and then he also claimed that he'd been
working behind the scenes to fight
against this bill now if it concerns you
that the company which produces so much
children's entertainment in our country
has now come out so forcefully in favor
of sexually grooming children well that
means you're paying attention and also
if you're paying attention you you've
noticed how the left
wields the power to bring even the most
powerful corporations
in the entire country under its thumb so
think about this the left
made up
out of thin air
a completely fictional story about a law
that outlaws the word gay completely
fictional
and they managed to get that story told
by every major news outlet
and by the white house and now by the
biggest media company in the entire
world
this is the power they wield
now they gain this power by claiming
each successive generation as their own
and they do that by reaching each
successive generation early and often
so we talk all the time about the
situation in schools
only this week we started focusing on
the proliferation of these weird cultish
summer camps where children are
subjected to even more intense barrage
of often sexual indoctrination yesterday
we heard about the sexy summer camps
quote unquote for kids where a group of
lgbt witches that's how they identify
themselves
teach you about the wonders of
masturbation and do-it-yourself
abortions today there's this report in
the daily wire it says a sex education
summer camp for children in grades three
to five so this is a different one okay
we'll include a condom demonstration
in grades three to five
among other camp activities the sex ed
summer camp for students as young as
seven is scheduled to get rolling this
june in northern indianapolis the camp
is set to run june 6 to 10th 8 am to 5
pm
at a barbecue joint in the city
uh quote at this age kids are primed for
level-headed learning they are
information gatherers there is no shame
or ickiness associated with using
band-aids and that same philosophy is
applied to condoms and other barriers in
this body-positive curriculum according
to the flyer in addition the kids will
not be separated by gender when learning
about puberty bodies and sex because
quote gender is a spectrum and everyone
needs to learn about all bodies
according to the flyer
so these will be this will be
in the middle of indianapolis
condom demonstrations for
seven-year-olds
that parents will choose to send their
kids to
and if that wasn't bad enough also today
last but certainly not least creepy
we have this video first posted by log
cabin republicans of richmond posted
disapprovingly i should mention
which shows a a a guy named chase in
budage who is uh pete's husband
leading children at a gay camp in a
pledge to the gay rainbow
see for yourself
all right i pledge my heart
to the rainbow
affirmation and equal rights for all
now those were young kids in there uh
that doesn't tell you exactly what ages
they were but you're looking at middle
school at least um you know
up and probably into high school
that was a gay camp for kids in iowa
now
i can remember when i was a kid um
their camps were pretty common kids
would go to summer camps i went to a few
camps myself
but back in those days back in the dark
ages you know you'd go to camp and you'd
learn how to camp you know you'd there'd
be like tents you'd learn outdoor skills
you'd learn how to make a fire uh maybe
for older kids there'd be like rather
for younger kids a camp would involve
arts and crafts you'd play games you'd
do archery those sorts of things that's
what camp was
now we have sexuality camps for kids
and by the way there's there's no
corollary for this for heterosexual kids
so it's not it's you know what you hear
from the left is oh well you'd be fine
if this was a if these were straight
kids no i a a heterosexuality camp uh
for kids i would not be in favor of
either
any kind of sexuality camp for kids
is grooming
is creepy and disgusting
now that footage that you saw there
comes from the amazon prime documentary
about bootages buddhija's campaign for
presidents called mayor pete
so they proudly filmed this and they put
it in the documentary
and it's been on amazon for months and
the funny thing is nobody noticed it
until now because nobody watched the
documentary and then finally someone had
like one person watched it and saw this
this is early on in the documentary it
was horrified by it put it on uh put it
online and then it went viral
by the way right after
the groomer jason led children in a
pledge to the pride flag
organizers at the camp had the kids make
drag taters
if you're wondering what that is those
are potatoes dressed up like drag queens
so now i did say that when i was a when
i went to camp when i was a a little kid
we did things like arts and crafts
so that's arts and crafts too
just with a little bit of a different
flavor to it
yet somehow even though this clip has
gone viral and people are disgusted
the real point gets lost
the the blasphemous pledge that they're
doing there to the pride flag
you know that's that's bad that's what
people are focusing on
but the worst thing is that kids are at
a sexuality camp in the first place
once we've
accepted and tolerated the existence of
literal grooming camps for kids
all the rest of this follows
automatically
in fact a pledge to a pride flag is
about the tamest thing you could hope to
see in this context
at least jason wasn't giving the kids
condom demonstrations
though maybe they saved that for when
the cameras were off i don't know
still the pledge is quite significant
because
this is how they want the kids to see
themselves and to see the world they
want kids from the youngest ages to
define themselves by their sexuality
and to have loyalty first and foremost
and exclusively to their victim group
their their sort of sexual tribe
of course young kids don't really have a
sexuality at all
which means that the first task is to
rob them of their innocence and of their
childhood so that they can be molded and
exploited
this process plays out in schools and in
media and hollywood and they even have
whole camps set aside now for that
purpose
they do all of this out in the open
they film it and put it on amazon
they're proud of it
because this is their culture this is
their society for better or worse and it
is only for the worse
this is what we face what our kids face
pure evil
we might as well fight it
um with all we have go all in
because there's no other choice
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if you've ever experienced
nausea whether it's from the stress of
the world or some bad indian food then
or whatever it happens to be uh then you
you've gotta check out relief band
relief ban is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness which is
my particular plight that i deal with
anxiety as well migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more how it works is relief band
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of your brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal in your brain uh that's that's
being sent to your brain letting you
know that you're supposed to feel sick
it's um it sounds complicated but it's
actually very simple all you got to do
is just put the relief band on and
you're going to feel better right away
other great thing no no side effects
there's nothing no drowsiness or
anything like that you put it on you
feel great relief bad makes a great gift
for any time of year right now they've
got an exclusive offer just for my
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code walsh you receive 20 off
plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee that's
the best offer you'll ever find for a
leaf ban anywhere but you have to use my
code so head to relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com use our promo code walsh for 20
off plus free shipping
this is from breitbart house democrats
passed a 1.5 trillion omnibus spending
bill after hours of delay and democrat
confusion what else is new house
democrats passed the 1.5 trillion
omnibus spending bill which was
separated into two votes the first half
focusing on security funding passed with
361 votes four and 69 votes against
second half uh featuring the remainder
the spending pass with 260 votes for 171
against
um
some of the some of the the highlights
are low lifes low lights for this it
says a republican study committee
messaging document obtained by breitbart
news found that the bill has many issues
including quote
the bill would spend over 100 billion on
green new deal initiatives and advance
racial justice through department of
agriculture programs
we're advancing racial justice
through the department of agriculture
because everything
that is under the left's control must be
used to advance their ideological agenda
you know nothing can just be what it is
nothing exists for its own sake
the department of agriculture can is not
going to be focused on agriculture it's
going to be focused on all of the
left-wing priorities which have nothing
to do with agriculture
the bill also contains 100 million
dollars for environmental justice
activities at the environmental
protection agency
and 75 million dollars for low or zero
mission vehicles
uh 26 billion in food stamp funding
this is the first spending bill to
include earmarks
no protections from chinese espionage in
grants to the national science
foundation
increases national institute of health
funding by 10 percent
and provides 66 million dollars for the
racial and ethnic approaches to
community health or reach uh an increase
of eight million dollars from last year
now
you would never know
looking at a spending bill like this
that were like 30 trillion dollars in
debt because there's no concern for that
at all just keep spending the money
now we should also note that they did
they the democrats tried to ram this
through
as quickly as they could um because it's
you know it's only it's only one point
you know whatever it is seven 1.5
trillion it's only 1.5 trillion dollars
that we're spending
so no reason to spend any time thinking
about this this hundreds of pages of
course nobody read it
and they were trying to ram it through
get it done as quickly as possible
because the democrats um wanted to go
and in fact right now right now are at a
uh a retreat
in philadelphia at the ritz carlton what
they call their issues conference and
that's a three-day retreat at the ritz
carlton philadelphia
where you know supposedly they get
together and talk about the issues
but really it's just a great vacation
for them
so in the middle of all these crises
that we're facing
in america and in the world
and as americans can no longer afford to
put gas in their car to go to work and
all these other problems um democrats
are taking off for the rest of the week
to go to the ritz carlton
now
unfortunately for them there was some
tragedy last night because uh really
their conference was supposed to start
last night
and uh on wednesday
and one of the first things they were
going to have when they got there was uh
there was they have a drag performance
the drag queen was going to show up and
they were going to you know watch a drag
show and unfortunately they were not
able to get there in time to watch the
drag show maybe they'll reschedule that
i don't know
but this is
you know
i think people on the right will say oh
how out of touch they are they're so out
of touch
the democrats that in the middle of all
this inflation you know uh gas prices
they're going to go to the ritz carlton
and watch a drag show
and
the common talking point from the right
is that oh they're out of touch and this
is why they're doing that
i don't think they're out of touch at
all in fact
they're very in touch they're very aware
of the fact that they can do this they
can get away with it
the out of touch would be that they're
blissfully unaware they don't even
realize how it comes off
no they know they just number one they
don't care
they don't care how you feel about it
they don't care what's happening with
you
and they know that there's no one to
hold them accountable
the media is not going to do it
in fact
having the drag performer there only
gives them more coverage cover from the
media
that actually makes it more acceptable
for the media because hey if you
complain about it then what are your
homophobic
so that's what they're doing now also
there was 13 billion dollars for ukraine
in the bill so um and that's not the
only foreign aid but we're gonna be
shipping 13 billion off to help ukraine
help secure ukraine's border
uh our border not so much
all right
let's go um here we go down to florida
where a man named corey pujols
has just been given some very good news
despite punching an elderly man in the
face and killing him
corey will not be going to prison
he's getting house arrest and probation
house arrest and probation for pujols uh
for his victim the morgue
so let's back up and give some context
here nbc reports it says a florida
dunkin
donuts employee was sentenced to two
years on house arrest after he pleaded
guilty to fatally punching a customer
who used a racial slur corey pujols uh
27 was initially
uh charged with aggravated manslaughter
after he punched a 77 year old man in
the jaw following an altercation in may
pleaded not guilty but agreed to change
his plea for the lesser charge of felony
battery the incident began when the
customer identified with associated
press as vanell cook
became upset over the lack of service he
was receiving he was apparently in the
drive-through line and the service was
pretty slow as frankly it tends to be at
dunkin donuts
and uh you know they should take some
customer service classes from from
chick-fil-a like you chick-fil-a you
could get a chick-fil-a line
this is not really the point at all but
i'll just say chick-fil-a you get in the
line and there's 30 cars in front of you
and you get in that line and
then you can look over
the parking lot and there's dunkin
donuts and there's three cars in line
and the person who's three cars back
will be in that line longer than you are
30 cars back in the chick-fil-a
so wasn't get any service to the dunkin
donuts he was upset about that he went
inside um and then nbc continues police
said cook and uh pujols start started
arguing and that cook called the dunkin
donuts
was black a racial slur a criminal
report affidavit states that the
customer called him the n-word and then
he told uh cook not to repeat it and he
did repeat it
and then corey
jumped over the counter and punched him
in the jaw cook was knocked unconscious
and fell hitting his head on the floor
and had a skull fracture and contusions
on the brain and then he died three days
later
now
so this is an interesting case for me
um because the victim vanille cook
is or was rather by all indications a
total scumbag and we do have to
acknowledge that
not only was he berating a minimum wage
customer service worker and calling him
racial slurs because he was upset about
the service being too slow but he was
also
uh according to the reports i've read a
sex offender and a pedophile
it's probably telling that apparently
nobody from cook's family is 77 years
old
nobody from his family showed up to the
sentencing nobody showed up and in the
family and and you know
protested the fact that
such a light sentence
now i'm personally not at all sad that a
pedophile is dead
um what's more even leaving aside the
pedophile bit
if you start screaming in another man's
face
and insulting him
and i don't care what words you use you
start screaming in another guy's face
and insulting him
you deserve to get punched that's my
feeling you deserve it
if you're in a physical state where a
punch to the head might kill you
then watch your mouth is probably the
best way to go
so i i don't see someone as a victim you
start getting in someone's face and
screaming at them and they give you a
chance to stop and you don't
and they even warn you they're gonna
punch you in the face and you keep going
and then you get punched you're the
victim you know i don't really see it
that way you really brought that upon
yourself
i actually and i also don't think that
hitting someone is automatically worse
than insulting them
now i think we have this is sort of this
effeminate uh view that people have this
really feminine view that people have
that the worst possible thing you could
ever do is
physical violence is always the worst
thing no i don't think that's worse than
going up to in a guy's face and um you
know verbally spitting spitting in his
face basically or actually spitting in
his face
so
that's the way i feel that's my personal
view
and yet my personal views on these
subjects aren't reflected by the law
not necessarily nor should they be
perhaps at least until i'm a theocratic
fascist dictator
like i personally think that if you get
in a guy's face and start insulting him
and you get punched that's on you you
had that coming
but that's not what the law says and
probably i'll admit that the law can't
really that's not a precedent you can
actually set her you probably want to
set
so um
then you then you think that really what
happened here is a guy was killed for
saying a bad word
do we want to set a precedent that
allows that
i mean
corey
the dunk donuts employee he didn't know
that cook was a pedophile as far as i
know so that didn't that didn't factor
into this
um
he also didn't hit him for screaming and
screaming at him and berating him
generally he hit him specifically for
saying the n-word
and now he gets house arrest
so is the precedent
that people who say this one magical
word
can be killed
the judge in explaining the sentencing
specifically mentioned this he mentioned
a few things he mentioned how well he
didn't mean you know this was not an
intentional homicide he wasn't trying to
kill him he punched him one time
um and that's true you know that does
factor into that it's not premeditated
murder so that's going to factor into
sentencing but he also mentions
the the severity of the horrible word
that was used like that's because of
that specific word
that's one of the reasons why he's not
going to go to prison
is that the precedent now that if
someone says this word to you and you're
a certain certain skin color and they
have a certain skin color then you can
kill them
that's certainly the feeling of people
on social media who are celebrating this
to them
they even living aside pedophile leaving
all that aside
cook deserved to die
not because he was a pedophile or
anything else but because he said that
word
you know
and the court seemed to have vindicated
this position
which which to me seems rather troubling
and you worry about the precedent there
also i think we could say this
completely destroys the idea of any
anti-black systemic racism in the court
system i mean this was a black guy who
killed a white guy for saying a word
and isn't even getting
no prison time for it
if our court systems are systemically
racist in an anti-black way then you
would think it wouldn't work out that
way
so interesting case there though
um all right let's move to this
not to pile on um but
we talked about matt schlapp in the
daily cancellation yesterday he's the
guy who runs cpac
he runs the american conservative union
which which which itself runs cpac
uh which of course is the largest
conservative conference conservative
gathering in the country every year
and what we talked about yesterday is uh
he sent out a tweet basically in support
of leah thomas the trans swimmer who's
um invading women's sports women's
swimming and stealing all these medals
and also exposing himself in the locker
room to women he he put out a you know a
tweet in support saying calling for
compassion for leah thomas and also
referring
to leah thomas as a her
he's trying to backpedal from that he
issued some statements and trying to
back away from it
well since this conversation has started
now about match lap and about cpac and
everything else
um there's another video that has now
gone viral
this is matt schlapp
very recently at the last cpac which
just a couple weeks ago
and um he's explaining in this interview
with with uh with someone there why cpac
didn't have any pro-life panels or
speeches this year now think about this
for a second this is cpac supposed to be
a conservative conference
the pro-life movement is one of the is
one of the foundational
aspects of the conservative movement
generally speaking at least that's the
way i would i see it
and
there's a chance that roe v wade is
overturned this year
so in a year when the pro-life movement
is making all this progress roe v wade
might be overturned and you have cpac
and you don't even talk about the
pro-life movement at all
through three days there's no time to
talk about it
um well match lab was asked about that
and here's the reasoning that he gave
tell me if you find this
convincing you and mercy have a very
strong pro-life record and uh some of
the folks that have come to cpac were
concerned that it might not have as much
of a strong pro-life message
particularly in a year where roe v wade
could be overturned i wonder if you
could speak to that yeah you know we
always say every year we should have a
pro-life panel
and i broke that i was like i don't want
a pro-life panel and they're like why i
was like because i think everything's
pro-life that we talk about everything
should be life-affirming
and we've tried to take that spirit in
what we talk about with so many issues
now we'll have speakers that are for uh
abortion and for legal abortion and we
have people here with disagreements on
almost every major issue we they used to
be a problem for us and my belief is
that should not be a problem if you
agree with this movement on a couple of
things like if you just think taxes
should be cut or the government should
do less we want you a part of this
coalition you might not check every box
that a conservative uh would normally
check uh you should feel welcome to come
here there's a lot of non-republicans
here there's a lot of non-conservatives
here there's a lot of people who just
are here because i love trump
there's a lot of different reasons why
people are here some people are simply
here because they hate socialism right
and they're still trying to figure out
their views and i think we should
welcome them with open arms but on the
pro-life question i think that's
foundational to having a society
that uh that can proceed and be
welcoming and uh and grow by the way
population has a lot to do with uh
economic growth and so i just think it's
imbued in throughout the conference
well
i don't think there's any good reason
that the head of c pack could have given
for personally cutting the pro-life
panel there's not any good reason so
there's nothing he could have said that
would that i would listen that i would
hear and say well okay i i understand
that
so acknowledging that ahead of time
even so
um that's about as bad as it gets like
that's all of the all of the out of all
the bad reasons you could give for
cutting the pro-life panels and pro-life
speeches from cpac uh those reasons were
the worst
and so really it's it's two things
right he's got two two uh reasons why
there's no pro-life at cpec
one is everything is pro-life that we
talk about he claims and also we want to
be a big tent and we want to you know
appeal to lots of people and uh you know
if there's if someone is
for lower taxes but they're not pro-life
we want them in a tent as well so let me
address both of these
first of all that's it's just not true
that everything is pro-life this is
something this is why it's really
troubling to hear from the guy run cpac
because this is exactly what people on
the left try to do
they want to expand pro-life
and make it so general and vague that
it's that it's you know meaningless it
doesn't mean anything
so even they as people who are in favor
of abortion in fact you hear this
from from some democrats
who are fully in favor of abortion at
every stage but would still say oh i'm
pro-life
even though i'm in favor of killing
babies
and then they all and this is something
that they flip around and try to use
against people on the right and they say
oh well you say you're pro-life but
you're not in favor of
spending more on entitlements or you're
not in favor of a student loan
forgiveness you know if you're pro-life
then you should also hold all of these
other views because all of this also is
is part of the pro-life cause i've
decided
they want to expand it make it general
make it vague so it doesn't mean
anything anymore i mean if everything is
pro-life
then nothing is pro-life
but it's not true that everything is
pro-life the pro-life movement
is very specifically focused
on the issue of abortion
now it's true that the reason why we're
opposed to
abortion is that we believe that human
life is sacred
and uh we believe that it is always
wrong to intentionally destroy innocent
human life that's our position that's
why we're that's why we're pro-life
that's why we're against abortion and
yeah we so we need to take that position
and apply it consistently sure
so all that means is that if we're
saying it's always wrong to
intentionally destroy innocent life then
we should be against intentionally
destroying anything in my human life in
any context
which we as pro-lifers are there's
there's no context where we're okay with
intentionally destroying innocent human
life
but that is the pro-life ethic that
that's the pro-life position
there is
only one area in american life right now
where it is actually legal
to intentionally destroy innocent human
life and that is in the womb and that's
why that is that's the fight that's what
we're focused on
so if you're not talking about abortion
and why abortion is wrong then you're
not talking about the pro-life issue
this is a this is a way of evading the
issue
by again making it general and making it
vague
and this idea of of the big tent so we
want to bring people in
you know if you're if you're if you're
in favor of lower taxes but you're not
uh but you like abortion we want to have
you in the tent
well if our tent is that big then there
is no tent
okay then the tent doesn't exist anymore
there is no movement if our movement is
that big then what what is the movement
where where are we headed exactly the
thing about a movement is that you need
to be headed in a certain direction like
you're moving right
now at least among the left they they
know which way they're moving they know
where they're trying to get they know
what their objectives are
and that's why they're so successful one
of the reasons why they're so successful
in the culture is because they stay on
message they know what they want they
know where they're going
and that's why they have success
the problem we have among conservatives
is that like nobody has any idea what
we call it a movement but where are we
going exactly why are we doing why are
we going there what why does any of this
matter
what is this sort of overarching what
are our overarching or underlying
principles
and values
here's here's what i'll say you know
someone who is in favor of a lower if
you're if you are in favor of lower
taxes
but you're pro-abortion
then i have nothing meaningful in common
with you we're not in the same movement
so you like paying less in taxes great i
mean so do i but that's
that's surface level
you can't
have
a meaningful and powerful movement
grounded in that hey we're all we're all
a bunch of people who like us having
less of our money taken away sure okay
i'll tell you this i have a lot more in
common
and ali beth stucky put this out on
twitter and i agree with you said you
know i've i have more in common with a
pro-life socialist than i do with a
pro-abortion capitalist and i think that
summarizes it perfectly it's exactly how
i feel
i'm not in favor of socialism
but capitalism is not my religion
it is that's not the banner that i'm
marching under that's not what i'm
charging into battle for
fighting for capitalism
i like capitalism and i think it's
better than any other options on offer
but what i care about is protecting
human life protecting children
and so if you're with me on that then as
far as i'm concerned we're on the same
side
all right here's more republicans
embarrassing themselves representative
maria salazar of florida
was uh caught outside the capitol
yesterday and she was asked about her
support for a no-fly zone in russia
which is something that you started you
have a no-fly zone um
that means you're going to war if we are
enforcing a no-fly zone
um
over ukraine that we we are going to war
with russia the people who are
advocating for this do they even realize
that you would hope that our elected
representatives would understand that
but it doesn't appear that they do let's
listen to what uh this representative
said
and and do you support a no-fly zone in
ukraine i've absorbed i support
everything that has to do with punishing
vladimir putin and helping the
ukrainians wouldn't that mean direct
conventional warfare with russia i don't
know what it will mean but you know
freedom is not free so you don't know
what a no-fly zone will mean if you have
to shoot down russian planes i mean of
course so conventional war with russia
listen
thank you
these are
the morons that we have
running the country
and also leading the republican party
oh sure let's uh freedom isn't free
you're talking about if we did what you
want to do
maria then we would be getting involved
in a um in a global war you're talking
about starting world war three which is
what happens when you start shooting
down russian jets
um
and
your justification for doing that is
that freedom isn't free
okay your justification is like a song
lyric
you might as well start how about do you
have a haiku you have a poem you also
want to read to us
her justification is a bumper sticker
based on a bumper sticker slogan
she's going to send us into world war
three
and that's stupid
and it's incompetent
but it's also evil okay
she's
despite how it may appear these people
are actually not well
they're pretty stupid but they're not as
stupid as they seem
she she obviously knows what what a
world war it would entail she knows that
she knows that it would involve lots of
americans dying
and she just doesn't care about that
certainly doesn't care about it enough
all right i want to mention this also uh
quickly from the new york post it says
keeping up with the kardashians
doesn't come cheap the world's most
famous families headed to hulu with
their new reality series the kardashians
premiering
on april 14th if you want to watch it
and according to the cover story today's
issue of variety the streaming platform
ponied up a rumored nine-figure deal
for the uh for the kardashian clan which
parted ways with the e-network in
september 2020.
uh matriarch kris jenner says well money
always matters i think that anybody
would be foolish to say that money
doesn't matter anymore
hey uh matt schlapp kris jenner she
invite her to cpac right she's a
capitalist
so we're on the same she's part of the
tent now kris jenner let's give kris
jenner
a
leading speaking slot at cpac next year
so she could talk about why money
matters
which i agree with her it does but i
that's that's all i have in common with
kris jenner it's just that we both agree
that sure money matters i like making
money we can agree on that
the only reason i bring this up is that
um i just think it's it's funny because
this conflict between kim kardashian and
kanye west and connie is very upset that
kim kardashian kardashian's running
around with pete davidson and everything
else
and we keep hearing that uh
kim kardashian is she's a she's a victim
because she just
all she wants is privacy and kanye west
keeps putting her private
life out there and it's not fair and
she's a she's a victim she's being
harassed
i think this underscores the point i
mean kim kardashian wants privacy
this woman does everything she possibly
can
to get her private life out and viewed
by the public
i don't i don't think she really has at
this point
a private life or an interior life of
any kind i don't think she's capable of
it
um she she can only she she needs the
cameras on her all the time it is a need
and yet this person wants privacy also
by the way can i just say
not that i care about that much about
the celebrity gossip
but
i
as as i followed it very
kind of uh off on on the on the edges
and the outrage at kanye west because
he's upset about pete davidson and i
guess he he put out a music video
recently where there's a he he depicts
himself in cartoon form
burying pete davidson alive and people
are really upset about that
and by the way if you're upset about
that then you know don't once again
don't listen to any eminem songs from 20
years ago you know he's literally
killing his ways he's one entire song
where he murders his wife
uh in the song but by the way it it's
actually
yes you shouldn't make songs about
killing people and depict yourself in
cartoon form bearing them alive i think
we can agree with that but
it's not all that strange for a man to
be very very upset and angry
that his wife left him and is parading
around town with another man
it's actually pretty normal
so there are a lot of crazy things about
kanye west this is actually one of the
most normal things
he's really upset
and whatever trying to embarrass her
making physical threats against the guy
that she's shacking up with that's all
pretty normal actually this is maybe the
most normal kanye west has ever been
it's as far as i'll go in defending
kanye west because by the way he is also
parading around town with his own uh new
woman so he's not exactly a victim here
but
i feel like i should mention that let's
get to our comment section
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's go right to um
the video comments i think we actually
have a couple i'm feeling optimistic
this time let's go to clip seven
hey matt walsh look at what my husband
got me for my birthday
a trip to the dmv
that's amazing see that is what we need
in the video comment section and that is
someone committed that is a license
plate so now you can get a if you
haven't thought it you get a custom
sweet baby gang license plate she has
spg forever on her license plate that is
amazing uh i i just have to i have to
applaud you for that you are not
certainly not banned from the show
you know i give you a place of great
honor and distinction now
um
that's that's incredible and this really
sets the bar i think actually for the
sweet baby gang how committed are you
actually do you have the license plate
as far as i know also by the way no
one's gotten a tattoo yet with sweet
baby gang
i
i hesitate to bring that up although i
just did because now i feel like
someone's actually going to do it but
that's how i know you're really
committed
how about right across the forehead
and if you do that don't play me i'm not
advocating i'm not advocating anyone do
it i'm just saying that no one has done
it yet and so it makes me wonder how
committed the gang really is
all right we got one more video to play
this is clip eight
hey matt
to make the video comment uh section a
little more serious i would like to ask
you this question
what do you think of the moon landing
that allegedly happened in 1969
do you think it was real or do you think
it was fake
frankly um i used to think it was real
and i used to make fun of people
who
doubt it
but i've seen enough evidence that it
was fake
and for those listening
i can direct them to a facebook group
called the moon landing hoax there's a
ton of evidence scientific and otherwise
that
it was fake but i would love to hear
from you matt
and it's kind of related to the
space subject and aliens that you are
you know uh a fan of so i would like to
pick up your mind uh tell me what you
think was it real or do you think it was
fake and sbg for life
um well i would love to hear so you're
in a facebook group that says the moon
landing was fake
and there's a lot of evidence and this
is the the interesting thing i've
noticed about people who support the
moon landing conspiracy
is that they always tell me about the
evidence but they don't really tell me
what the evidence is so i always he i
hear about this evidence this
mythological evidence i mean what i i
hear great things about the evidence
i've just never really heard what the
evidence actually is
um no i don't i don't think the moon
landing was fake at all i i think this
is just it's it's
so many reasons how can i even go
through all this um
[Music]
uh
well okay here's one piece of evidence
that i have heard
um and this just shows you i think this
is a representative sample of the
evidence and it shows you how weak this
claim is
and that is that uh if you look at some
of the footage it looks like the the
flag is moving
um like it's blowing in the wind but but
hey there's no wind on the moon you know
so
and of course
it turns out that like when you put the
flag in it causes it causes uh motion
which will make the flag move a little
bit and there's no atmosphere so the
movement will last longer but but also
this all all of the evidence that you're
marshaling whatever it is
it presupposes
that our government
hatched this conspiracy theory
or rather hatched this conspiracy and
this plot and they executed it and they
fooled the entire world and yet they
left these really obvious
breadcrumbs out there like what they
didn't know that there was no wind on
the moon
or all the stuff about the shadows and
oh look at the how the shadows are
there's perfectly logical explanations
for all that but but again it it
presupposes that the people who
were able to execute this plot
still were not able to outsmart like
people on reddit
and i just find that to be totally
absurd um also
you know it would also require
not only that the entire government is
in on it
and like all nasa and all the astronauts
and all of them have been lying this
entire time and they've all kept quiet
like none of them have ever come out and
said anything otherwise so you're
looking at um this cooperation across
many government agencies you think about
how vast this conspiracy would have to
be it's not just a couple of people it's
not just it's not just the actual people
who went to the moon who would have to
be the liars okay
but it's
hundreds of people
if not thousands across multiple
government agencies are all on the same
page to execute this plot
and they have and they have stayed
disciplined
through across decades
look if you know anything about our
government and how it works you know how
ridiculous that is these people can't do
anything they can't they cannot
cooperate to achieve anything
just to change a light bulb in the
capitol building it takes 57 different
people it costs 600 million dollars just
to do it so you think that they could
fake a moon landing and fool the entire
world and not only that
but other world governments are also in
on it because they would know by now i
mean we've got
russia would know
that we faked it why haven't they come
out and exposed it this is something
that could easily be exposed now
with all the technology that we have and
the satellites and telescopes they could
easily expose it no they were never here
so it's a conspiracy among the entire
government
and other world governments for some
reason have decided to stay mom about
this and not tell anything not tell
anybody it's it's
and there's just no reason like it's an
interesting hollywood plotline
you know it's an interest it's a fun
story to tell and maybe you could write
a book or something like a fictional you
know fictionalized history
um
where the moon landing is fake but
there's no reason to there's a lot of
reasons to think that
it's not fake including some of the ones
i just said there's no real good reason
to assume that it was
um all right
let's see and and also one other thing
why haven't we faked like why did we
stop faking
you know why haven't we faked uh why did
we fake the mars landing that's really
if you got a fake uh
an expedition to outer space why are you
faking landing on
a rock
a big glorified rock
orbiting the earth
why did we fake the mars landing next
you know it seems like we went to the
moon
and there there there were multiple
expeditions to the moon but we haven't
gone back in decades and we haven't
really done much
and that is actually how you expect the
government to work it has a major
success
very rare successes
followed by decades of failure
and
um
you know just kind of treading water
that that actually is what you expect
from the government
all right
let's see a couple of uh written
comments here indie man says sexual
abusers always tell their victims to to
never tell anyone especially their
parents or or it will hurt them or bring
shame to them or whatever works
um
this don't tell the parents thing is
beyond dangerous yeah this is why we say
that there are groomers and predators
because this is as you point out exactly
what
sexual predators do this is exactly how
they operate the first thing that they
do is that they make sure they condition
that's what the grooming is they're
conditioning their victims and they're
making sure the victims are not going to
talk to parents or any other authority
figure
and that's what's happening here and as
i said it's out in the open
jamie m says well the anti-lynching bill
is basically saying are you willing to
stop lynching black people it's a yes or
no question it's obviously virtue
signaling but i mean how do you vote
against this
um right exactly that's that's
the game they're playing or it's like
the classic from when i was in school
the one you can't do anymore but when i
was in school it was the does your mom
know you're gay you know yes or no
question there's no way you can answer
without affirming the proposition
um
and that's what they're doing here
that's that's the spot they're trying to
put republicans in is basically that
that's actually why the bill was there
trying to coax republicans into voting
against it
and yet i'm sitting here saying i think
they should have voted against it
and i do think that
because when you start playing the game
and you start dancing to their tune it
never ends
and so if instead the republicans in a
unified way had come out and said no
what they're doing here isn't it's it is
a waste of time it's pointless it's
virtue signaling
it's actually grotesque the way that
they're using racism and lynching and
all this stuff as as a political uh
cudgel as a prop as a pawn
how about coming out and explaining that
rather than going along with this thing
that you know is totally absurd
and finally zimmer handcraft says matt
is so close to saying taxation is theft
i love it
well
um i would not say that across the board
only because
no one has really explained to me
how you can
have a government without some form of
taxation
and if you're saying well let's not have
a government no one's explained to me
how you can have a civilized society
without some form of government so in
order to have a civilized society you
need some form of government or to have
some form of government you need it to
be funded and so you need some form of
taxation uh which is why i wouldn't say
taxation is theft in general but there
are many forms of taxation that are and
i do think that the income tax is theft
especially the way the income tax works
now where they go in and take your money
before you get your hands on it yeah
that i do think tonight's the night it's
the premiere of our next big hit the
hyperions the pre-show begins at 8 30 pm
eastern to make so you got to make sure
you head to daily wire youtube channel
and you set a reminder to catch the live
streaming you're not going to regret it
um this movie has no political agenda
it's not woke it's all about
entertainment and you can clearly see
that in the trailer check it out
[Music]
my name is vista mandelbaum
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges is this real yes ma'am
this is real
well i want that too
it's the police they want to talk to
whoever's in charge
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
yeah i mean yeah if you think so
calling all hyperions
on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
shots fired
god come on give me my gun
suit up for adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
trying to destroy me
next question how's the family the
family is um
oh
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
well the hyperions is a family film with
some throwback vibes and it's 100 worth
the stream we're gonna be streaming it
again tonight at 8 30 p.m eastern for
all of youtube to see this the last time
we're going to be streaming any of our
movies on youtube so if you want to see
all the content we have coming
down the pike then head to dailywire.com
subscribe and you won't miss any of the
content against dailywire.com subscribe
also as if we didn't have enough
amazing content for you we're excited to
announce that this weekend ben shapiro
is hosting a new interview on sunday
special with bill maher you know that's
going to be a great conversation this is
without a doubt one of the most
fascinating conversations
um that we've that there's they've had
on the sunday special they've had a lot
of great conversations um it's free from
censorship of course and full of
interesting opinions and it's available
early to daily wired members starting
saturday morning so
get ready for an entire weekend of
amazing content only at the daily wire
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to a married couple in virginia hannah
and blair keely who are getting some
media attention because of their claim
that they have never once in 30 years of
marriage argued or raised their voices
with one another never once never done
it now they for some reason released a
joint statement to fox news digital
where they made this claim and also
imparted seven tips so that you also can
have a perfect relationship
now i do kind of like the idea of
releasing joint statements to the press
with random facts about your marriage
like my wife and i um could release a
joint statement and hold a press
conference about the fact that we have
never once through our entire marriage
owned a microwave
that's true so maybe we released a joint
statement
who wants to know or cares is the other
question
anyway right up front in assessing the
legitimacy of this claim and also the
credibility of the people making it
there there are a few strikes for them
and against them now here's something in
their favor they've been married for 30
years and they have uh seven grown
children
now if you want to claim to be a
relationship expert
you're not even in the running unless
you're married obviously and have
remained married to the same person
but to get to expert status you have to
at least have i think three decades
under your belt so they're just over the
line there and you have to have raised
children yeah i i sorry i don't want to
hear any relationship advice from
childless people
because it's a different ball game once
you have kids on the scene these people
have seven as far as i know all of their
kids are currently not in prison none of
them are serial killers as far as i know
so the keeley's did something right all
that is to their credit
there are some red flags though in the
article hannah is described as a master
life coach and her husband is in
marketing so you see the combination
here life coach marketing sending this
out claiming they've never had any
arguments you know maybe there's
something there um actually on her
linkedin bio hannah describes herself as
america's number one mom coach and
founder of mom mastery university it's
also she's a reality tv host
now i'm not sure who america's number
two and number three mom coaches are or
how these things are ranked
or if number two and number three know
that they're number two and number three
and would agree with that i have no idea
um now no doubt
there are some wise people in this world
who give great advice
okay
you're looking at one of them but when a
person goes into the business of being a
wise person who gives great advice and
aggressively markets themselves as such
you begin to become a little bit
skeptical
because
the first thing any wise person knows is
that you should not go around claiming
that you are wise socrates could have
told you that the whole concept of life
coaching i think is a bit absurd for
this reason and also because there's no
requirements right in order to be a life
coach
anyone can wake up one day you could
have it overweight out of shape
unemployed alcoholic could wake up one
day and say you know what i'm a life
coach now
and i'm an expert in life
and they can just start coaching you on
how to live so i find that dubious
but we could put aside
most of that and look at what the kiwis
are actually saying about marriage
most of the tips they give are pretty
good um pretty obvious and kind of
cliched but they're valid nonetheless
tips like share your feelings and
expectations and challenge each other to
grow
now these
tips are not actually necessary i mean
you don't need to tell a woman to share
her feelings there's no reason to write
that down no woman no no wife is gonna
read that and say you know what i should
share my i never thought to share my
feelings with my husband um that's you
know wife wives generally don't do
anything but share their feelings um so
but that's that's all fair enough some
tips are bad
they offer the classic never go to bed
angry thing in the explanation we're
told hannah and blair keeley insist it's
important for couples not to go to bed
angry that's because nighttime is when
humans often encode their cognitive
experiences from earlier in the day
in a couple's own words anger towards
your spouse can easily turn into a
belief if you don't manage the thought
prior to bedtime how do we do this they
continue to always affirm the love you
have for that person even if there's no
resolution the ultimate conflict
resolution is making the decision the
conscious decision to love
and the problem here is that anger is an
emotion you can't simply turn off and on
like a light switch all the time so if
you're buying into this ridiculous idea
that you should never allow yourself to
fall asleep while you're angry at your
spouse all that means is that is that
you're going to force yourself to stay
awake and your spouse to stay awake
while you continue to hash out your
issue
until you aren't angry anymore but it's
pretty rare that people get less angry
and arguments get less tense the later
it gets
sleep deprivation tends to fuel anger
and irritation not cure it
okay so in fact many times the best
thing you could possibly do when you're
angry is go to bed that's actually the
best thing
um
like 99 of the of the arguments that
you've ever had at night you would've
been better off just going to bed
and you wake up the next morning
now with some rest and a little bit of
time and and a lot of times you see that
what you were angry about was kind of
unimportant and silly um i have gone to
bed angry at my wife before i've never
woken up angry at her though so that's
the point
but even if i ever did
that's okay because anger is not the
worst thing in the world arguments are
not the worst thing
and this ultimately is my problem with
this life coaching duo they probably
know more about marriage than i do i'll
accept that but i am familiar with being
a human being and i know um what i know
about being a human being is that anger
and conflict comes in the bargain so
they present never arguing as an ideal
you know something to strive for but but
is it
let's think about that how could you
actually manage
to go decades without ever so much as
arguing with your spouse
or or with anyone that you spend that
much time with
one way is to be if you're both perfect
like christ himself
um assuming that's not the case here
then we're left with other options not
another is to be emotionless robots or
lobotomy patients
if not that you know if you aren't
perfect and if you have emotions
and you aren't siamese twins joined at
the brain who think and feel exactly the
same all the time then the only other
way to totally avoid arguing is to
suppress your anger when you feel it you
have to always 100 of the time keep the
lid on tamp down any anger that you feel
and funnel everything through the use of
i statements and other therapist
approved conflict resolution strategies
now if you do this always all the time
you may never argue but is that really
ideal
should we be presenting arguments in a
marriage like an objectively bad thing
to be avoided at all costs
does the fact that you've never argued
if that's true
make you more of an expert and give you
more credibility or less
now i admit that maybe i'm biased here
because my wife and i are both a couple
of stubborn sons of guns and we both can
be argumentative by nature and neither
of us probably would have
wanted to marry someone who is at all
times meek and mild and avoids conflict
that just sounds boring frankly but my
bias aside it seems to me that an
argument is simply when two people
have diverging ideas about something and
they both are insisting on their own
point of view
that's an argument and it's not it's not
bad there's nothing there's nothing
necessarily bad about that
this is another feminist just like the
idea that uh
i mentioned before two men are in an
argument and the worst thing that ever
happened is any kind of physical
altercation
well there's also this idea that the
arguments themselves are always bad
things
um
arguments happen when people are
asserting contradictory viewpoints
now there are bad ways to assert your
point of view if you're screaming and
cussing that's bad
obviously in a marriage between a man
and a a woman if it's a if it's this is
an argument between men and women if
you're getting physical that's always
bad also if you constantly feel the need
to assert your view about every little
thing
then all you're going to do is argue and
that's bad but if you never assert your
view if you never plant your foot on the
ground and say no this is how i think we
should go about this and i'm insisting
we do it this way if you never ever do
that
well then your conflict avoidance
becomes dishonesty your spouse won't
know who you really are what you
actually think what you actually feel
because you're always conforming
yourself immediately to whatever the
other person wants or feels
i hardly see that as ideal
now the point isn't to avoid arguing but
rather to argue well i think
i don't mean argue well as in knowing
how to destroy your spouse with facts
and logic though you should be able to
do that and i have done that to my wife
before whether she realizes it or not
but what i mean is is arguing in a
healthy way
which means keeps keeping things in
perspective
not blowing every little conflict out of
proportion
it means staying on topic okay never
saying anything that starts with oh yeah
remember the time when you
it means letting the other person
actually say their piece and it means
allowing the argument to end
so
once you've said what you need to say
and they've said what they need to say
let it end go to bed like leave the room
whatever arguments can be healthy but
the unhealthy one have the healthy ones
have time limits
every healthy argument can turn
unhealthy if it drags on too long
marital spats are like you know gremlins
don't feed them after midnight
don't keep it going past a certain point
say what you need to say listen to what
the other person is saying and then move
on that's a healthy argument such things
do exist
they're even i would say an important
part of your marriage
and that's why
i'm not going to cancel the key lease
themselves because they seem like nice
people but the idea that they're
proposing here is what i'm going to
cancel today and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
florida's parental rights bill passes
the senate the deep state changes its
story on bio labs in ukraine and trump
explains how he deterred vladimir putin
check it out on the michael knowles show